in an interview last fall Laurence
Olivier articulated something that's
troubled many actors for a long time he
said I detest the word media I think
it's nonsense to differentiate between
the platforms on which an actor plies
his trade I think it's nonsense too so
if anyone wants to know whether the
presenters of the next award are radio
television stage or film actors the
answer is simply yes I give you Maude
and Joe Bea Arthur and Peter Boyle
to be introduced by charlton heston with
a quote from Lord Olivier leaves Maude
and me practically speechless then I'll
talk first job and I promise I'll
recover in time to have the last word I
never doubted it the fact is that this
Academy show is proof positive with what
Lord Olivier said live on this stage on
your TV sets at home on radio for the
Armed Forces and on film at different
times around the world and for that
great audience we'd like to present the
nominees for best achievement in short
subjects in a live-action short subjects
the nominees are frog story
Ron Sat loaf and Bray Gideon producers
Norman Rockwell's world an American
dream Richard Barclay producer solo
David Adams producer and the winner is
the winner is Norman Rockwell's world an
American dream which would pave
well getting an Oscar for the first time
is quite a moment and I truly thank the
Academy for that moment on behalf of my
two partners Gabi mone who did the
scenario Robert doob Elwood directed the
film our editor Burt rash P the lyrics
have Fred ebb and the music of John
Kander a lot of love went into this
project cause that's what surrounds
Norman Rockwell and to him my sincerest
thanks
the nominees for best achievement in
animated short subjects are a Christmas
carol richard williams producer
kamasutra rides again bob godfrey
producer top-top Nijel code Rajic
producer and the winner is the winner is
a Christmas carol richard williams
I'd like to thank the writer Charles
Dickens the producer Charles Jones and
one artist in particular Richard Purdum
who sat up for nine months
drawing with me till midnight every
night and Roy Nesbit Abe Levitt Oh
Vibram Cormac Janeane Aarthi
Sergio simonetti and my son Alex who did
the voice of Tiny Tim my mother who
helped draw it God blessing everyone